he called your forehead nine months  pregnant  [Laughter]  what were you thinking at the time you  enjoyed it i know it was amazing i i i  thought it was nice you know giving me  that talk uh but obviously we're getting  in the ring  all that talk don't mean much  once you get knocked out so  uh it's exciting though i'm very excited  to uh piece him up and uh finish him off  i can see he got visibly riled up by a  few of his comments yeah yeah it was  annoying me it was is it really it was  pissing me off i was like  do you know who you told you too bro  like what are you doing  you you can't  talk to me like that and be like you're  gonna knock me out in this night like  you're capping you're you're chatting  dumb  oh man look he was chatting the most and  yeah yeah  so i was alright cool we'll see just  wait just wait you know